[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAN NACHMANY: Hello, everybody.
My name is Ran.
And actually I'm
from Israel, and I
lead the developer relation
out in Google Tel Aviv.
And today I'm going to
talk to you about battery
and how it can be more
efficient in that manner.
But first I would like
to make a quick poll.
Looks familiar?
Anybody use this?
Raise your hand.
OK.
What about this code snippet?
Anybody wrote something
similar to this?
Opening HTP connection,
fetching some websites.
Raise your hand, guys.
OK, let's do it this way.
Anybody didn't write
something like that?
[LAUGHTER]
Get out.
Anyway.
OK, so you must be
asking yourself,
hey, everybody's doing it.
What's the big deal here?
Why we've got this
weird guy talking?
Accessing the network, fetching
some data over the internet
is commodity.
Everybody is doing it.
What's the big story here?
Well, it turns
out that accessing
the network, like
opening HTTP connection
or especially on
cellular networks,
it has a significant
impact on battery life.
In fact, that's the number
one battery killer today.
If you check and see
what apps are doing,
what's killing your battery,
what apps are actually
doing on your phone that kills
your battery, it won't be GPS.
It won't be the screen.
It will be network.
It's true, GPS is a pretty
good battery hogger,
but most of the time it's off.
While accessing
the network, apps
are always accessing
the network,
and today we're going to fix it,
And if you still
ask yourself why
we should care
about battery life,
I can share with you a research
that we've done at Google.
It took us years to
conduct this research.
And we learned that
when the phone is dead--
there's no battery before.
The phone is dead-- the user
is less likely to use any app.
[LAUGHTER]
Yours as well, OK?
So you may want to keep the
phone running a little longer.
So the first thing
that we'll do,
we will try to
understand how things
are working under the
scene-- behind the scene,
under the hood.
How so networks are
actually working.
So it turns out that
wireless phone like this one
are actually wireless.
There's no cable here, right?
We rely on radio transmission,
radio communication
back and forth from my
cell phone to a cell tower
to a base station which
is located out there.
This means that
inside the phone,
there's a little chip
set with the radio
transmitter and receiver
that transmits radio
frequency, radio communication
to the base station, which
receives the communication,
processes it, and sends
some stuff back.
Now every communication, every
time we want to send something,
we need frequency.
We use frequency, and
frequency is expensive
because frequency is limited.
It's a physical resource.
It's not IP.
We're running out of IP address.
Let's make IPv6, and
suddenly we have more.
It's a physical thing.
It's a physical limitation.
Think of this room.
There's only so much
space inside this room.
I cannot put 1,000,000
people inside this room,
just not enough space.
Same thing with frequency.
We don't have enough frequency,
and actually the cell tower
cannot speak and communicate
and talk and allocate frequency
to 100% of its clients
100% of the time,
simply doesn't make it.
So instead, the cell tower--
I'm going to give you a moment
decides which clients,
which customers,
which cell phones
will get frequency.
He allocates frequency
dynamically over time
to do clients, to
different subscribers,
and this way, they communicate.
Just to give you a
rough idea, we're
all here in this convention.
We're probably all registered
with a cell tower which,
I don't know, about half a
mile away, and typical cell
here in this area will
serve, I don't know,
2,000 people, 2,000 cell phones.
But it can only talk to eight or
12, depends on the technology.
In modern country,
actually it's 16.
But in the United States
it's kind of falling behind
when it comes to same networks.
So over the years,
different technologies
have emerged to optimize
specifically that,
to make the allocation process
much faster, more efficient,
basically to get
more beats per hertz.
Were talking about
HSDPA just UPS.
What you guys probably know is
a 3.5, 3.75 generation or OFDM
and OFDMA, which is LT or 4G.
This is how the radio state
machine inside any cell
phone in this room looks like.
This is what
happens when we want
to make a transition,
when we want to send
a bit over the internet.
Now it's a pretty
self-explanatory diagram,
so it can move forward.
I see this guy here with a
question mark above his head.
Oh, no.
OK, uh, I made a
simplified version.
Let's think that we
have three states.
The first one is idle.
In idle, our radio
has zero throughput.
No frequencies allocated to it.
We can't transmit
even one single bit,
but we're hardly
using the battery.
We are hardly using any
power, only two milliamps,
which is practically nothing.
Now if the user opens
an app, and that app
wants to send something to the
internet and receive something,
we need to move
from idle to DCH.
DCH stands for
dedicated channel.
In this mode, the
base station actually
allocates frequency
to the client,
to the cell phone in a constant
manner, in a periodic interval,
like clockwork,
allocates frequency.
In that mode, again, to make
things easier to digest,
we have high throughput,
but we actually
consume a lot of power.
Now let's say we're getting that
frequency, which transmitted
whatever we needed to
transmit, and now the cellphone
doesn't need that
much bandwidth.
The network understands
that, and the base station
tells us the cell phone,
hey, move from DCH to FACH.
FACJ stands for
forward access channel.
Frequency is still being
allocated to the cell phone,
but not like before,
not like clockwork,
but every once in
awhile, we get frequency.
We'll be able to
transmit and receive.
In other words,
again, just to make it
schematics let's say that we've
got half of the bandwidth,
and we're using
half of the power.
We're running in this mode until
we're done with the network.
We don't need the
network anymore,
and then the cell tower
will tell us, hey, move back
to idle where you're not
consuming any frequency.
And that frequency can
be allocated elsewhere.
Now those transitions, actually,
they don't happen right away.
They take time.
It takes about two seconds
to move from idle to DCH.
Think about it.
User opens your app.
Your app wants to fetch
something from the internet.
The user actually
waits about two seconds
before you are able to
send the very first bit,
and it happens a lot.
Furthermore, in DCH,
it takes the network
some time to understand that
this specific client that we're
allocating frequency to it,
doesn't need that bandwidth.
He's not using it.
About eight to 10
seconds, depends
on the configuration
of the network,
and same goes with FACH.
Now those tail times,
that's basically
frequency that has been
allocated and nobody needs it.
Nobody's actually using it.
That's a waste of
frequency, which
is a huge problem to the
AT&T, Horizons of the world.
But we need to
remember another thing.
In cellular network, there is
no such thing as being quiet,
which means that if a
frequency has been allocated,
you must transmit something.
I got a cellphone,
move to the CH,
did whatever transaction
it needed to do,
got the frequency.
Now the cellphone
doesn't have the app,
doesn't have
nothing to transmit,
but the base station still
allocates frequencies
to that phone.
That phone has to
transmit something.
What do we transmit?
Random bits, zeros and ones.
We have to transmit something.
There are a lot of phrases
that like to do that.
I'm not going to go
into it right now.
You can ask me afterwards,
but the bottom line, they
will understand now that those
tail times from this age to FS
age to idle.
This is pure energy
that goes to /dev/null.
OK, that's energy that
we just throw away.
We're transmitting something.
Transmitting something is
very expensive battery-wise,
and it just goes away.
So now that we understand
how those networks operate,
we can ask ourselves what does
it mean to us as developers.
And at the end it all boils
down to two main things
that we, as developers,
need to focus
on, less radio, less data, OK?
That's what we're going
to talk about today.
First thing, I want
to go over some name
common mistakes
that we've seen lots
of people in lots of
apps doing, and it's time
to put that to an end.
First thing, periodic traffic.
Now we used to do
periodic traffic.
Let's say we want
to upload analytics
or do location updates,
or just keep live, OK?
Sending heartbeat messages
back and forth to the server
that we're still alive.
Here's a use case from
a music streaming up
that we've looked at.
This is a screenshot
from a tool called
ARO that was developed
in AT&T when I was there.
I am going to show that tool
later and elaborate a bit more,
and as you can see, basically
what this tool does,
it looks at the
network, requests,
and it analyzes what
the radio state was.
And as you can see, the music
file in that music streaming
app was downloaded as one
big chunk at the beginning.
OK, you can see we're
in DCH, and we're good.
But then every 62
seconds the app actually
sent about the payload, which
is about 2 kilobytes of data
to the server, analytics.
What is the song, the volume?
What the user did,
what are foregrounds?
What are backgrounds?
Stuff that they wanted to know.
And every pic here,
every 62 seconds
we actually moved the radio
from idle to DCH, FSCH,
and back to idle.
That's a lot of energy
that was wasted.
How much is a lot?
It turns out that
0.2% of the data
actually consumed 46% of energy.
We talked with them.
Back then that is three
years ago I think.
They batched the analytics
to piggyback that when
the file is being done
with it, and they actually
reduced battery consumption
by half, which is amazing.
Second anti-pattern is
multiple connections.
Everybody's doing
it including myself.
We need to download several
images from the website.
We will open several
HTTP connection,
and we'll do multiple
gets from that website.
But here's another thing
that I didn't tell you
about until now.
In cellular network,
every TCP connection
introduced some overhead because
it needs to be encapsulated.
So we're adding bits at
the beginning and the end
of the packets which means that
every TCP connection reduces
the overall throughput
that we have.
If I have a radio channel,
a cellular channel here
that can give me one
megabit per second,
and I open four TCP
connection at the same time,
I'm not going to get 250k each.
I will get less,
around 220 each.
That means that we
lower throughput.
The user needs to wait
longer for the data,
and it also means
that we're spending
more time in DCH or
FSCH mode, meaning
I'm draining the battery.
The third anti-pattern
is duplicate content,
basically downloading
things that we already know.
First problem is when the
app downloads something
from the server,
and that something
doesn't have any
caching information,
so the app can't cache it.
Let's say the app
downloaded an image.
The image doesn't have
caching information.
The user sees that.
Exit the app, and two seconds
later, he goes back to the app.
We go down.
We go back and download
the same very image
that we downloaded
two seconds ago.
Waste of time.
Waste of money.
Waste of battery.
The solution is to
use headers, the right
headers like Max Age or
Expires when you send something
to your client.
And then the client can use it.
Second problem is that content
with caching information
the cache hasn't expired, but
it is being downloaded anyway
by the client.
We've seen that happen a lot.
So when we write some code
that goes and fetches an image.
But they know we don't actually
check if that content has
expired or not.
So the solution is simple.
Don't do it, OK?
I don't believe it.
You're leaving me.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, friends.
Anyway, third problem, content
that has been downloaded,
cached by the client.
The cache expired,
but the actual file
hasn't been changed
on the server side.
It's the same file.
So usually what the client will
do, it will go in say, hey,
my local cache has expired.
Let's download
that content again.
But instead, the client can use
an if-modified-since header.
And then if the content hasn't
changed on the server side,
the server instead of
sending that image back
will send three or
four not modified.
And then the client knows that,
hey, my local copay is still
valid.
I can use it.
Instead of downloading a big
chunk of image or whatever,
we're downloading a very small,
only headers, only the HTTP
header.
Last anti-pattern,
connection management.
So I know that most
of us are using
HTTP URL connection or
an OkHttp or whatever,
a library that gives
us transport layer.
But in some cases, we
need to actually take
of connections ourselves to
do some low-level operation
in the socket level.
If we're doing voice over
AP or SIP or whatever.
And we've seen several
mistakes there.
The common one is that
we open the connection.
We use it, and then
we don't close it.
We don't call
socket.close because we
think that, hey, the
TCP will time out,
and the TCP stuff will
close the connection for us,
and actually it does.
But what happens is that in
order to close the connection,
we need to send TCP
resets to the side,
and in order to
send that TCP reset,
we fire up the radio
from idle to DCH
to FSCH and back to idle.
That's a waste of energy.
Another common name
problem is that when
we open a connection
just to have
one ready for when we
need it in the future,
and then we find
out the radio just
for the three-way
handshake [INAUDIBLE].
So if you do need to manage
your connections yourself,
open connections only
when you need them.
You use them as
much as you want.
You're done with them,
please close them.
So, now that we've covered
the common mistakes
that a lot of
people are doing, I
want to talk about some advanced
techniques that will help you
to become a better new member.
And our goals are less
radio time and less data.
Now it's easy to say--
it's a little bit harder
to implement-- because when
you think about it, in our app,
we're dealing many,
many, many transactions.
There are so many
code paths that
will lead to a transaction,
to a thread that will fire up
a network transaction.
It's very hard for
us as developers
to say which transaction happens
when and how to deal with it.
So in order to make things
a little bit easier,
I've decided let's--
what we're going to do,
we're going to categorize
network requests to three
different buckets.
First there is the stuff
that the user asks us now.
The user clicks on
the article, and he
wants to read that article.
He wants to get into that
specific post or whatever.
We need data right
now for the user.
We need to go now and
bring the data in order
to display that to the user.
Second type is those
small data updates
that we need to send
to our servers when
or while the application
is running, again,
like analytics or location
updates and whatnot.
These usually will
be small payloads,
and we care about them only when
the app is actually running.
The third type is
when we want to send
a relatively big change of data
to the server in order to sync.
Let's say, uploading
a bunch of photos
or doing an email sync like
Gmail does or address book
and contact list sync
like WhatsApp does, OK?
We don't really care
about exactly when
that transaction will happen.
It's big chunks, and it usually
happens in the background.
Now the second and third types
we can optimize by batching,
and the first one can be
optimized by prefetching.
And we're going to talk about
these two techniques now,
so let's start with batching.
Batching basically we take
a bunch of transactions
that happens over time.
And for every
transaction, we actually
pay a radio transition state.
Those transitions
from this FACH.
I'm going to say
that a lot today,
and we batched them together, so
we paid the overhead only once.
Now the easiest way
to do that is by
simply when you have
a network request,
don't execute it immediately.
Simply send it to a queue, OK?
It can be a very simple
queue or something
more complex like, I don't
know, content provider.
It can even serialize
that transaction
to persistent storage,
so you want to use it
if the app gets terminated.
Now you would ask yourself
when do I purge my queue?
When do I actually
go and send that?
So an easy answer, let's that's,
when we reach the threshold.
Let's say, I don't know, 10
transaction in the queue.
Let's bash them together
and send them out.
That works, but when
we think about it,
actually our phone is doing
a lot of stuff in the system,
and there is a very good
chance that another app will
use the radio before the
threshold is reached.
So we would really like to get
notified when somebody else is
using the radio.
The radio is already hot.
It's in this edge mode.
Why don't we piggyback on that?
It will be a very good idea
for us to piggyback on that
and transmit, and that's
exactly we introduced
JobScheduler in Lollipop.
How many people here
use JobScheduler?
OK, you're in the right room.
Good, so how do we do that?
Basically, we specify job ID,
the job that needs to be done
and some concerns like what
network type do we want,
and time.
And actually, we can say,
hey, some except constraints
I won that transaction to
happen only one charging.
But job scheduler was
introduced only in Lollipop.
What happens if you're
running on pre-L devices.
So first thing you could
do is you Sync Manager
and SyncAdapters.
SyncAdapters are great for those
third type of network requests,
for those cases when you
need upload a bunch of stuff
to the server or to sync data
from your phone to the servers.
The things that are
not time critical
and usually huge loads of
data, big chunks of data.
This is what Gmail is
using to sing Gmail.
This is what the
address book is using.
This is what WhatsApp is using.
Basically, I can't
think of an application
that will actually sync
something and not using
SyncAdapters.
So SyncAdapters are
great for the third type.
But what happens
with the second type?
Those small data
updates that accrue
while the app is running.
SyncAdapter just
wasn't built for it,
and it introduced way
too much overhead.
For those, we have
a GcmNetworkManager,
which is very similar
to job scheduler.
Basically, let's say we
want to schedule a task that
will run from, I don't know,
from five minutes from now
to 15 minutes from now.
You've specified the
task, and you just
need to override
the single method.
And when you inherit
from a GcmTaskService
and you need to return
either results successful,
results failure, or
results reschedule.
If you want to debug
when you're running
with a just GcmNetworkManager,
you need to somehow create
that trigger to tell
GcmNetworkManager,
hey, I want you to
trigger that task.
I want you run it, and there's
an ADB command for that.
There are some caveats
and limitations,
so you better go to the
communication about it
a little bit, but basically
it's works and it's great.
Now let's talk
about prefetching.
If in batching we wanted to
grab a few transactions together
and wait until we have
enough and set them together,
prefetching is all
the other way around.
Basically what happens.
The user opens the app.
We fetch some data
from the internet.
The user looks at the data.
He waits the wait.
In the meantime, the
radio goes back to idle,
and then it clicks on something.
And when it does, and we fetch
some more data, you a seat.
And then he clicks on something,
and we go and fetch some more
data, and so on and so forth.
Prefetching is all about
predicting the future,
predicting what data we will
need during this session.
What data the user was likely
to ask us to download for him
and actually download it now
before he even asks for it.
Think about it.
Not only we are improving
battery life dramatically,
we are actually improving
the user experience
because when the user
actually clicks on something,
the data is already there.
He doesn't have to wait
for it to be downloaded.
First question, how much
data do we prefetch.
It's a tough one.
So a quality prefetch
will fair on a 3G network
will be around between 1
to 2 megabits per second.
On faster networks
like 3.5 or 4G,
we could go up to 5
megabytes of data.
But there's another
way to look at it.
Since it doesn't make any
sense to prefetch data
that the user doesn't want
or that the user won't see,
actually we can think of
it from a different angle
and say, hey, let's fetch enough
data for the next minute or two
minutes.
OK, that's usually the average
session length in application.
I depends on the
application category,
so actually I really encourage
you to go to analytics
and look how much time
users spends in session
and you're ops, and then you
can optimized specifically
for that style.
So that's a good approach,
and I'll go with it.
But we can improve it a
little bit and be adaptive.
Let's they now we want to
look at what the user is doing
and what the device is doing.
For example, do we
fetch more of a Wi-Fi?
Hell, yes.
Do we fetch more while charging?
Of course, we download the
internet while charging.
I don't care.
Fetch less while
the user is walking?
For sure, because
users when they walk,
their attention span
to our app is lower.
Every session type when walking
is around 20-25 seconds, which
is a good thing because if it
was 2 minutes like when we're
standing, people will
get into parking cars
or fall from cliffs or I don't
know what will happen to them.
OK, fetch more when
the user is driving?
Depends, if you're app
is all about roadblocks
and the hero moment
of the app is
while the user is driving, yes.
If the users is
driving, fetch more.
And you can actually
tell what the user
is doing, if he's driving, if
he's walking, if he's cycling
by using activity
recognition API, which
is in the Google Play services.
Do we fetch more
over a fast network?
If we're in 2G,
let's fetch less.
If we're in 4G, let's fetch
more, et cetera, et cetera.
But we talked about [INAUDIBLE]
and how much to prefetch
and how to change the amount
of data that we prefetch.
Now I want to ask you another
question and take it a notch
up.
When to prefetch,
what do you think?
When to prefetch?
When is the right
time to prefetch?
That's actually a
question you can--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: When we're
downloading data anyway.
That's a good place
to batch actually.
Prefetch is
predicting the future.
AUDIENCE: Login.
RAN NACHMANY: What?
RAN NACHMANY: Login.
When the user opens the app.
AUDIENCE: The user logs in.
RAN NACHMANY: User
logs in or user
opens the app, that's a good
place to prefetch, yeah.
AUDIENCE: At night.
RAN NACHMANY: At night.
At night it's not
a really good idea
because if the user
opens the app at noon,
probably the data from the
night is already obsolete.
But we're going to talk
about BG updates in a second.
So actually the right
answer, the optimum point
in time to prefetch is right
before the user opens our app.
Think about it.
We save the user those two
seconds from idle to DCH.
He opens the app, and the
data is already there.
No need to download anything.
No need to refresh.
The app is fresh.
The data is right
where it needs to be.
The only problem
with this approach
is that our crystal ball
API is still in beta.
[LAUGHTER]
And we haven't released it yet.
What?
Yeah.
But you can get to
the early access.
I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
So instead, we need to
take a different approach.
And that's to do background
updates similar to what you
said, let's object at night
or when the user is not
using the app, so when
he will use the app,
the data will be there.
Now beckoned updates,
can be very, very tricky.
And we need to ask ourself
what we update and how
in order to make that process
efficient and effective.
Efficient means that we
don't want to pull the server
and say, hey, is
this something new?
Is this something new?
And actually drain the
battery really, really quick.
And effective, we don't
want to fetch data
that the user won't see, OK?
The whole thing here
is to fetch data
that the user will want to see.
Predict the future.
So in order to understand
what to update,
I, again, segment the contents
to three different buckets.
The first thing is
the what's hot, OK?
This is the data, the
information that users
are most interested in.
This is why they have download
your app in the first place.
If we're talking
about the news app,
that will be the top headline.
If we're talking
about sports app,
there will be the current scores
or live objects from the game.
This is the data
that users care most.
If you don't know
what the data the user
cares most in your
app, A, it's a shame.
B, go to analytics and take
a look what users are doing,
and then you'll find out.
The second bucket is
that interesting stuff.
This is stuff that's
not the what's hot,
but it's stuff that
the user told us
that he's interested in.
For example, if we're
talking about the news app,
maybe we have a
user that is very
interested in the final
section and another user who's
very interested in
the, I don't know,
science section or
political section.
So the user actually
told us, hey,
I'm interested in
that information.
It's not common.
It's not for all the users, but
specific users told us, hey,
this is interesting for me.
And then there is all
the rest of this stuff.
Now when I look at
background updates,
I'm thinking of,
all right, let's
take a look how we update
every each piece of content.
So for what's hot, my server
knows that something changed.
There is no new headline.
New results form from the
game, something new happened.
The server can actually
send us a GCM message
with the data embedded in it.
We can carry
payload of up to 4K,
if I'm not mistaken,
in every GCA message.
And actually, our client, the
app, can get this GCA message.
We don't show
anything to the user.
We don't pop out in the
notification, nothing.
We take the data, and we store
it in our internal database.
When the user will open
the app, all the What's Hot
is up to date.
It doesn't need to wait one
single millisecond to see that.
When it comes to
interesting stuff,
we can't use the same
approach because we
can't send everything to
everyone all the time.
We take a different approach.
Basically the server will
tell the users via GCM
that something has changed.
Let's say something has
changed in the final section,
all the users that starred
that said the final section
dates in their
favorite list, the app
will get the message
saying, hey there's
new data in the final section.
And then the app will use
backoff to pull that data.
And it will look-- let's say,
it can go in two different ways.
Option A, we get
this GCM message.
Something has changed.
We wait a little.
We go.
We fetch the data, and then
the user opens app perfect.
We predicted the future.
Another way that
this can go, it's
the other other way around, OK?
So we get a GCM,
hey, something new.
We fetch the data.
And the user doesn't
open it up, and then
we get another GCM
something new happened,
and we fetch the data.
And then the user opens the app.
It means that we've
had redundant updates.
We've wasted bandwidth.
We've Wasted energy.
In that case, when
we identify it,
and it's very easy to
identify in those cases,
we basically increase
our backoff exponentially
until we reach to
the right amount.
So there are users that will
open our app four times of day.
There will be users that
opens our app two times a day.
Pretty easy we'll find
the right frequency
to those background updates.
And all the other
stuff, we simply
update that when the
user opens the app.
It doesn't really matter.
We can't really predicted that
the user will want that data.
OK, third technique.
Now we talked a lot about
reducing radio time.
Now let's talk about
reducing payload size.
Here's a test.
There are two images
on the screen.
Who thinks the image on the
right is higher quality?
Two people.
Who think the image on the
left is higher quality?
Three people.
Who thinks I'm fooling you,
and it's the same image?
Most of the people.
OK, thanks for the trust, guys.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, actually one is 45k,
and the other one is 160k.
And third, and no one
here in this one room
could actually tell, hey, this
one is better than that one.
We can save a lot by compressing
our images correctly.
We don't need to go with
100% quality in JPEG.
Actually, if you look at JPEG
quality for the leading sites,
Google, Facebook, Yahoo,
et cetera, et cetera.
This is how the
big guys are doing.
Why don't you do the same?
And since it is big
on the barbecue,
and Colt was supposed to be
here, is not here, right?
Colt?
Good, so we can skip this slide.
You don't need to go see it.
All right, let's talk
about application resource
optimizer or ARO.
ARO, it's a tool that was
developed at AT&T several years
back when I worked there.
And I think about two years
ago, we've open sourced it.
What this tool
does, it basically
monitors all the network
transactions and activity
that we have that
happens in our app,
and it analyzes what
the radio states would
be for those transactions.
It also runs a lot of
tests against those anti
patters that I've just
showed you earlier today
and gives you an easy-to-digest
report how you are doing, OK?
So give me one moment to
rearrange my screens here,
and we'll be able
to actually see it.
OK, so wait another
second, and this
is going to be challenging
because I'm half blind,
but it's all right.
OK, so I took an
Israel application
so no one would
understand anything
because the content
doesn't really matter,
and here we can see, on
the screen, the report.
And there are a bunch of
tests that the tool did.
And obviously, green means
good, red not that good,
and you know that you need to
fix those items, whether it's
duplicate content or
connection management
or currently not being
zipped, stuff like that.
But we can do some
more with the tool.
It's extremely hard
to see from here.
We have an overview tab,
which basically tells us
how much energy we consumed,
how much energy was
wasted on radio
transitions, on signaling,
et cetera, et cetera.
But the most interesting part,
it is for me, is this screen.
Basically what we
see here-- these
are the screenshot that
I showed you earlier--
we can see here
the transactions.
We can see the transactions,
and actually the packets
that were sent.
And if we look at any
single point of time,
we will see on the right side
the actual screen and what
happened during that time.
So during this splash
screen, we can see here
what packets have been-- we've
downloaded, what we sent,
and we can immediately
take a look
and see that we were on
DCH, went down to the DCH,
back to DCH, down.
All those small
transactions should
have been batched into
one single big one
and save a lot of data
and a lot of battery.
Lets take a look at this area.
So the user clicked
here on something,
and he actually
entered this article.
This is a news
application in Israel.
OK, again, you don't need to
read what's happening there.
Now I can see some
transactions here.
And if we'll go
down and look, we'll
see that we actually downloaded
the article and the images.
But over there, there's
another transaction--
I don't see my pointer.
I'm going to point anyway.
Already, there's
another transaction,
and I don't understand
why it's there.
And obviously, I think it
should have been batched,
so let's click on it.
Where am I?
Here am I?
What changed?
Did the user see
anything different?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: The ads, exactly.
So the user was actually
reading the article.
The radio went
already to idle state,
and just to change
the ad at the bottom,
we fired the radio
from idle to DCH, FSCH,
and so on and so forth.
wasted a lot of energy.
A better approach will
say, hey, give me five ads,
and then the clients
will rotate them
without going to
network every time.
So there's a lot in this tool.
It's very hard to
actually go over it,
but I really encourage
you to try it.
It's called application
versus optimizer ARO.
You can find it in GitHub.
You can compile it.
There is zip file,
APKs, everything.
You will discover wonders on
your app if you will use it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: Yep.
RAN NACHMANY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: This
is your best friend.
Start here.
See what your green.
See what your red,
and all you reds,
actually, If you click on them,
you get some nice explanation.
Hey, you're doing this.
You're doing that, and even
in some case, not all of them,
pointer to the actual packets
that misbehaved, all right?
And then you can
actually-- in fact,
if you only very recent
few things in your code,
you will see a
tremendous improvement
just like get rid of all
this periodic bursty traffic.
And probably, you have one
process or maybe two that
are doing better
or improve prefetch
or let's do some batching.
Let's do a transport
layer that will
batch some background
request, et cetera, et cetera,
and you're there, OK?
All right, so we do have
some time left for Q&A.
So feel free to ask
whatever you want.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: Actually, yes.
Yeah, the question was, can
I see when the radio is hot
or what the state of the radio?
Actually the question
is yes and no.
You can see that in Android.
You can see it in your code.
The reason ADB command,
if I remember correctly,
it's ADB-B and then
space and radio.
Check the communication.
You can tell ADB that we can
take the log cut from which
buffer to present the log.
And there is a buffer for
radio, and while you're running
and your phone is
connected to your computer,
you can actually
seen in the log file
of the radio, what's the
state, et cetera, et cetera.
So if you want that during
debug to take a look, perfect.
But while running and
checking in your code what's
the status of the radio you
don't have access to it.
That's why you have GCM
network manager and then
job schedule that
will do that for you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: The question
was, can I run this tool,
ARO, in an continuous
integration and automated
testing environment?
Actually, I haven't tried
that, so I don't really
have an answer on that.
There shouldn't be
a reason why not to.
The only problem that it--
well, actually when I think
about it-- OK, so ARO,
the way it works you
have data collector.
First you collect the data,
and then you feed that data
into that tool that I just
showed you, which is basically
the analyzer.
Now the data can be collected
by using a specific APK,
or you can actually feed it
Wireshark dumps, TCP dumps.
So in your automatic testing
environment all you need to do
is run TCP dump and
dump those pickup files.
And then in the morning, feed
them to the analyzer and you
immediately will see if there
was a regression or not.
Another one, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: OK, so
in cellular network,
every TCP connection is
actually encapsulated,
which means that the
cellular radio here
and in the base station, they
add bits at the beginning
and the end of that payload.
So we actually add
more bits that we
need to transmit back
and forth, therefore
we reduce the
overall throughput.
The reason for that is that
in cellular network we often--
I don't know what the
political way to say that--
we often fake the
TCP state, all right?
' So think of it this way.
My phone opens HTTP GET
request to a server,
and we're a TCP
connection to a server.
And I want to keep that
TCP connection live.
That means that the phone needs
to send TCP ACK messages back
and forth.
Now the cell network
doesn't want those TCP ACKs.
They don't add any
value to the user.
They're not actual payload.
They just wasteful
frequency, and as I told you,
frequency is extremely
important to network operators.
So what they do actually
behind the base station
somewhere at the base
of the cell tower,
there's a big machine that looks
at all the TCP connections.
And when that happens, when
we open the connection,
that machine will start
talking with the server,
and it will send those
TPC ACKs on our behalf.
So we can shut down the radio.
We cam stop allocating
frequency that's cellular phone,
but the TCP connection
is still alive.
And while that server will want
to send something to the phone,
it actually sends something
to that big box that's
either it's called ASM gateway.
And that box will then
tell the base station,
hey, we have data to that
phone, give him frequency
and transmit the data to him.
So basically because
we needed to do that,
there's encapsulation
for advocacy connection
that's reduced over throughput
when we are adding connections.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: Yeah,
the best practice
is actually moving from
HTTP 1.0 to HTTP 1.1, which
is persistent connection.
So you open one connection, and
you run multiple get requests
on top of it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAN NACHMANY: So I
don't know what Retrofit
is using under the hood.
I can tell you that
OkHttp is perfect.
So OkHttp actually use
persistent connection
by default unless
the server doesn't
support it, which is great.
The only thing that
you need to make sure
is that you don't open
several-- or that you minimize
the amount of HTTP connection,
simultaneous connection
that you open, OK?
Anymore questions?
All right, so I guess
we're done here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]